es fühlt sich an wie eine ewigkeit aber
wir sind seit acht wochen eigentlich
bislang im lock down und am ersten
november als es losging hat man uns
versprochen nur noch einmal für wochen
zusammenreißen diszipliniert sein auf
freiheiten verzichten
doch jetzt geht der lockdown schon die
zweite verlängerung bis mindestens 31
januar mit verschärften kontakt regeln
brechen wir jetzt endlich diese welle
oder folgt die zweite dritte vierte
fünfte lockdown verlängerung im februar
märz april auch deshalb weil wir das im
chaos nicht in den griff kriegen und wie
sinnvoll sind die neuen einschränkungen
wie die korona 15 kilometer alleine
halten schule und wirtschaft das aus und
wann endet das im chaos
[Musik]
darüber möchte ich heute mit folgenden
gästen diskutieren der bayerische
innenminister und stellvertretende
ministerpräsident joachim herrmann der
spd gesundheit ab in der spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach der
fdp generalsekretär volker wissing und
der tübinger ob boris palmer der gerade
beim tatort ausgeschaltet hat und jetzt
bei uns ist herzlich willkommen sie alle
zusammen ja um mitternacht tritt die
verlängerung und verschärfung des lok
downs in kraft und ich möchte ihnen
einmal zeigen was einer der
einflussreichsten corona politiker wenn
man es so sagen will
neben der kanzlerin dazu an diesem
wochenende beim neujahrsempfang der nrw
cdu gesagt hat wir müssen den lockt an
den wir jetzt verlängern an einigen
stellen auch noch vertiefen
auch wenn es schwerfällt ich habe
verständnis für ich sage ganz ehrlich
jeden der der der sich ärgert und und
auch dem das zu viel ist und vor allem
auch für diejenigen die wirtschaftlich
so stark betroffen sind also jeder der
meint ist jetzt im februar ist vorbei
der es nicht seriös
wir sind jetzt wirklich klug beraten
jetzt nicht vorzeitig maßnahmen
abzubrechen oder uns in sicherheit zu
wiegen
ich weiß das klingt nicht so populär und
es ist auch kein sehr bequemer weg aber
es ist der einzige der in dem zelt herr
lauterbach hat herr söder recht geht der
lockdown am ende im februar märz weiter
also es wissen wir jetzt noch nicht aber
ich glaube auch dass es uns nicht
gelingen wird eine brauchbare ziel
instituts bis ende januar zu erreichen
erst da er davon aus dass bestimmte
massnahmen auf jeden fall in den februar
weitergeführt werden müssen
realistischerweise sollten wir uns damit
abfinden dass wir einen wirklich
wirkungsvoll locker und jetzt auch und
ich schlage ich sogar vor dass die ziele
incidents die welt etwa 50 liegt dass
die unterschritten wird dass wir
versuchen eine zielinsky dance von 25
euro woche pro 100000 zu erreichen aber
erlag aber 50 scheint ja jetzt schon
wahnsinnig unrealistisch zu sein im
winter wenn sie jetzt sagen wir sollen
auf 25 runter das heißt sie wollen
eigentlich einen totalen shutdown
lockdown sowie bodo ramelow es zum
beispiel in thüringen gefordert hat er
gesagt hat es müssen jetzt alle betriebe
schließen
nein du hast du das ist die frage nach
den betrieben ist ja sozusagen eine
frage nach der verschärfung
aber ich glaube ich schon dass der hier
ist die gelockten also die 50 und somit
auch die 25 jahre reicht wenn man erst
einmal da 50 ist dann ist der weg bis
auf 25 nicht mehr so weit denn der noch
da und wirkt umso stärker je niedriger
die zahlen bereit sind weil man dann ja
zunehmend auch die kontrolle wieder über
die panne megabit die gesundheitsämter
kommen dann wieder dazu wir können jetzt
keine und ließen kontrolle pandemie
leisten und somit wird er locker und
umso effizienter je niedriger die wert
das ändern wenn man dann einfach zu früh
aus dem block tor daraus geht weil ist
man innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit wieder da
wo man angefangen hat und dann haben wir
es möglicherweise mit anderen
gefährlichen mutation der b17 mutationen
aus irgendwann zu tun und kam noch
einmal eine ganz andere lage summe die
ich verliere nicht für die beschießung
der betriebe
ich spreche auch nicht vom märz aber ich
hielt es für falsch ist bei 50 sofort
abzubrechen wenn man da noch ein oder
zwei wochen durchhält kommt man doch wer
die kontrolle wieder gewonnen ist herr
palmer sie gehen in tübingen einen sehr
eigenen weg was die korona bekämpfung
angeht schützen vor allem alte schützen
die altenheime
wenn sie jetzt hören was herr lauterbach
sagt wie realistisch halten sie das dass
man überhaupt unter diese inzidenz von
50 infektionen auf 100000 einwohner
kommt und ist das auch wirklich
notwendig ich hab mir gerade noch mal
angeguckt jetzt im winter nach den
letzten daten des statistischen
bundesamtes wie sieht es in europa aus
50 länder werden da aufgeführt im
schnitt liegt die imsi dienst deutlich
über 200 in europa und kein land ist
unter 50 meine these ist im winter ist
er wir hatten nicht zu erreichen der 525
schon gar nicht wenn man es ernst meint
heißt es locker und durchhalten bis das
frühjahr uns redet so wie es letztes
jahr war also bis mitte ende april
meiner auffassung nach steigen aber
jetzt die schäden
gesellschaft an wirtschaft auch
exponentiell der innenstadthandel ist
schon auf der intensivstation der fällt
bald ins koma die insolvenzen werden
anrollen
ich meine wir halten das nicht durch und
ich als auch für falsch es so zu machen
wie herr lauterbach das vorschlägt wir
auf der kommunalen ebene verantworten ja
die nachverfolgung und ich sage ich
klipp und klar die funktioniert so dass
und ich bei der insel 150 genauso wenig
wie bei 150 unser problem sind nicht die
fallzahlen sondern die geschwindigkeit
unsere prozesse sind mittelalterlich
wenn man hat es mit telefon fax und
gedächtnis auch forschung das hat keine
aussicht auf erfolg das bewirkt auch gar
nichts das virus ist immer schön weg
bevor wir es gefunden haben und aus
diesem grund bin ich der auffassung dass
der zielwert der vorgegeben wird
falsches wir sollten uns an der
belastbarkeit der intensivstation
orientieren das ist da maßgebliche wert
noch mal ganz konkret aber was wenn sie
das hören was auch eine regierung
diskutiert wird wenn sie hören was
markus söder gesagt hat glauben sie dass
wir nochmal eine verschärfung erleben
werden weil die bundesregierung oder
viele länder ist eben nicht so machen
wie sie zum beispiel dass man sich vor
allem auf den schutz der alten
konzentriert was ist realistisch die
menschen wollen sie wissen wie lange das
noch gehen will wenn die politik an dem
ziel 50 oder ein lauterbach vorschlag 25
festhielt geht dieser lockt dann noch
mehrere monate wird massive schäden
verursachen dann möglicherweise gar
nicht viel nützen
ich bin der meinung das ist der falsche
weg ist und dass wir ab anfang februar
über lockerungen reden müssen die
schulen müssen wieder aufmachen
kontrolliert natürlich das hat sogar
lotta love befürwortet die kitas müssen
wieder aufmachen baden württemberg hat
es zum glück vor einige länder weichen
japan da immer weiteren verschärfung ich
meine schärfer als es jetzt ist geht es
nicht und wir können uns auch nicht mehr
abverlangen als wir uns schon
abverlangen für mich ist da irgendwann
das ende der fahnenstange erreicht und
diese 15 kilometer radien und die
politik nur noch einen freund treffen zu
dürfen
zum glück haben acht baden württemberg
das alles nicht mit das führt dazu dass
man die akzeptanz der menschen verlieren
meinem umfeld ist jetzt schluss schärfer
geht nicht mehr
die leute sagen ich mach da nicht mehr
mit wenn er allein erziehenden mutter
verboten wird ihre eltern zu treffen
gehört es bei den leuten einfach auf
lauterbachs forderungen hin oder her wir
können nicht weiter wir können nicht
schärfer
es reicht jetzt oder anfang februar
müssen wir kontrolliert wieder aufmachen
mit hygiene konzepten selbstverständlich
wir müssen auch leben kontrolliert
wieder aufmachen sagt boris palmer herr
wissing
sehen sie das genauso muss man ab
februar wieder aufmachen und vor allem
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie
markus söder hören der sagt naja wir
müssen ist noch viel länger machen und
dieser neue lockdown hat ja erst
eigentlich oder beginnt zum großen teil
erst ab mitternacht
mich stört dass die maßnahmen auch die
erklärungen einzelner verantwortlicher
wirklich jede logik verlassen haben
wir haben jetzt gehört wir können nicht
lockern weil wir die auswirkungen der
kontakte bei den feiertagen noch nicht
kennen wir wissen dass erst ab dem 17
januar und gleichzeitig erklärt man wir
müssen aber verschärfen
diese ankündigungen dass man verschärfen
muss passieren damit offensichtlich auf
einer nicht verlässlichen daten
grundlage
das ist sehr schwierig wir müssen ja die
menschen mitnehmen wir müssen ihr
vertrauen haben wir müssen auch die das
verantwortungsbewusstsein der menschen
als wert nutzen um die pandemie zu
bekämpfen
wenn man aber die logik verlässt dann
wird das kann ich schwer dann fangen die
leute an sich abzuwenden und das erleben
wir zunehmend ich finde es auch sehr
schwer dass es weder immer in den
minister aber herr wissing herbert er
wissen jetzt ganz konkret ich habe sie
gefragt müssen wir ab februar wieder
aufmachen wir müssen so bald wie möglich
lockern
bei den menschen soziale schäden haben
wir haben enorme wirtschaftliche schäden
die menschen vereinsamen und man darf
sich ja nicht vormachen dass das keine
folgen hat die menschen haben auch
gesundheitliche beeinträchtigungen viele
können ihren sport nicht nachgehen haben
deswegen ihre ihrer erkrankungen oder
all die dinge also wir müssen jetzt
aufhören mit dieser im
überbietungswettbewerb mit immer neuen
verschärfungen und ehrlich gesagt manche
dinge sind auch nicht logisch wenn
familie die zwei kinder unter 7 jahre
haben die nicht mehr die privat
organisierte kinderbetreuung geben
können
dann läuft etwas schief wir haben so was
in rheinland pfalz auch nicht umgesetzt
und das ist auch richtig so
und auch diese 15 kilometer regel ist
eine zumutung
das im markt für menschen in berlin
großstädten kein problem sein
auf dem land ist das nur die das massive
die freiheit über die 15 kilometer regel
reden wir gleich ich möchte einmal
joachim herrmann dem stellvertretenden
ministerpräsidenten von bayern ein tweet
von wolfgang kubicki zeigen der heute
massiv markus söder angegriffen hat hier
sehen wir diesen tweet und hermann gott
gott schütze was geht ihnen durch den
kopf wenn sie diese kritik von joachim
herrmann sehen wie gefährlich ist markus
oder für deutschland ich denke markus
söder hat das bayerische
ministerpräsident und den mitwirkenden
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in den
letzten monaten wirklich sehr viel dazu
beigetragen dass wir konstruktiv
diese schreckliche corona pandemie
angegangen sind die äußerungen von herrn
kubicki
na ja die sind auch für dessen niveau
und ich kann nur sagen ich hab das vor
über drei jahren erlebt in den
koalitionsverhandlungen in berlin wo die
fh herrmann wir wollen jetzt nicht immer
wir wollen jetzt wir wollen wir wollen
wir wollen jetzt in der
koalitionsführung sprechen sondern wir
wollen über corona sprechen deshalb noch
einmal die frage wie ihn herr genervt
wie genervt sind die menschen
mittlerweile von politikern wie markus
söder der bevor einloggt überhaupt
angefangen hat mit den verschärfungen
schon sagt wir müssen noch länger machen
das stimmt überhaupt nicht das hat er
nicht gesagt dass er nicht so gemeint
das hat nach den journalisten das so
verdreht haben
die staatskanzlei gestern auch
klargestellt in seinem grußwort an die
nordrhein-westfälische cdu hat er sich
bezogen auf die maßnahmen die in bayern
jetzt gleich einer guten stunde um 0 uhr
in kraft treten
die maßnahmen hat er gemeint mit der
aussage wir müssen jetzt die maßnahmen
noch mal verlängern und wir müssen sie
vertiefen aber herr söder
herr söder hat von februar gesprochen
herr herrmann das ist fakt da können sie
jetzt nicht sagen journalist etwas
verdreht
also ich habe hier das video der cdu nrw
mehr inzwischen angeschaut
ich habe daraus nicht genommen dass er
vom februar gesprochen hat er spricht
von der jetzigen verlängerung und es
bleibt dabei der herr kubicki hat noch
überhaupt nichts zu irgendeiner
konkreten verbesserung oder zum grillen
konkreten problemlösungen beigetragen
ich will aber auch zu der debatte jetzt
hier gerade sagen ich halte überhaupt
nichts davon jetzt abstrakt wieder über
55 oder 25 zu reden das entscheidende
ist doch dass wir in überall in
deutschland festgestellt haben dass kurz
vor weihnachten in vielen teilen
deutschlands die krankenhäuser kurz vor
der über lastwagen dass ich hab das auch
selbst hier in der region erlebt wo in
nürnberg krankenhäuser schon im
neuzugang geschlossen werden mussten
kein platz mehr war und und und und ich
habe aus thüringen die notrufe in den
letzten wochen gehört wir bringen nicht
mehr alle patienten unter und und und
das ist doch die realität das hat kein
politiker irgendwo erfunden sondern die
hilferufe kam aus den krankenhäusern wir
sind an der grenze wir sind gott sei
dank doch nicht so weit so schlimm
gekommen wie in bergamo zu im frühjahr
letzten jahres aber ja auch immer aber
wir sind an der grenze und das ist für
mich doch der entscheidende maßstab wir
können doch nicht in eine situation
kommen dass unsere krankenhäuser die
kurven wie patienten nicht mehr
aufnehmen können darum muss es doch auf
jeden fall mal als circa unbedingt die
maßnahme gehen und deshalb musste er
feststellen
die maßnahme die zunächst im november
und anfang dezember beschlossen waren
haben offensichtlich noch nicht gereicht
um die zahl der schweren infektionen so
weit zurück zu führen dass wir
jedenfalls da keine sorgen in den
krankenhäusern mehr haben müssen und
deshalb war es richtig dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz übrigens
wie der parteiübergreifend alle
ministerpräsidenten egal welchen
politischen lage ist genau diese
beschlüsse in der vergangenen woche
gefasst haben gott schütze uns vor
markus söder den satz möchte ich
trotzdem nochmal aufgreifen auch wenn
der herr man darüber nicht sprechen
möchte aber er wissen
gott schütze uns vor markus söder sehen
sie das auch so ich bin dankbar dass es
markus söder gibt ja wissen sehen sie
das auch so
das muss der herr man so sagen aber es
ist trotzdem schwierig die äußerung von
herrn söder sind in mehrheit im jahr
reichen sicht problematisch zum einen
sitzt er in einer ministerpräsidenten
runde dabei verabschiedet ein konzept
und erklärt immer ein zwei tage danach
manchmal sind nur stunden danach alles
würde nicht ausreichen
ich finde es schwierig wenn man
einerseits sagt wir haben keine daten
grundlage um öffnung und diskutieren
dass man sagt wir haben zwar keine
datengrundlage aber verschärfungen gehen
immer das geht immer nur in eine
richtung und das ist nicht gut begründet
und ich finde die äußerungen von herrn
söder heute dass er sagt einzelne
gesellschaftliche gruppen würden sich zu
opfern stilisieren mehr als
problematisch so mit solchen äußerungen
treibt man die gesellschaft auseinander
und wir haben es in dieser corona
pandemie ohnehin schwer genug den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt zu
sichern
und insofern kann ich wolfgang kubicki
es ärger wirklich verstehen und ich
finde auch die csu sollte sich damit mal
kritisch auseinandersetzen
herr herrmann ich möchte gerne mit ihnen
gelingen darf ich jetzt mal noch mal
fragen die von der fdp mitgetragen
landesregierung in nordrhein westfalen
die in rheinland-pfalz dienst schließen
holstein haben
doch jetzt auch den maßnahmen die die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
haben zugestimmt ist das jetzt so oder
nicht oder ich die fdp jetzt auch
oppositionskurs nein herr herrmann wir
sind konnten die täter nicht genau so
bekennt ich will ihnen auch ganz sagen
dieser lockt dabei ist die tonlage der
rituelle so als ob die fdp das anders
wollte aber überall dort wo sie in der
regierung sind beschrieben sind mit das
müssen wir mal schauen ja ganz ehrlich
ich habe als generalsekretär nie etwas
anderes gesagt als ich auch eigenen
landesregierung sage wir haben im
übrigen der pandemie nach wie vor eine
pluralistische demokratie und nicht den
auftrag eine politische einheit meinung
deutschlands zu arbeiten und es muss
auch gerade wenn es um so massive
grundrechtseingriffe gibt geht eine
politische debatte die grundrechts leide
das grundrecht ist ein ist ein stichwort
und darüber möchte ich ganz gerne
sprechen und zwar mit joachim herrmann
zunächst denn ab mitternacht teilweise
geht sie schon gilt die so
genannte beschränkung der
bewegungsfreiheit auf 15 kilometer um
den wohnort
das bedeutet in berlin ab stadtgrenze
darf ich mich nicht mehr weiter als 15
kilometer entfernen es gibt dafür
ausnahmen aber hermann wer hat sich
diese 15 kilometer eigentlich ausgedacht
und was soll das die 15 kilometer sind
als solche wie viele grenzwerte in
unserem land natürlich frei gegriffen
das könnten auch 14 oder 16 gleichen
sein aber da möchte ich gerne damals
gerne nach hagen da er hat mal ganz kurz
da muss ich nachhaken weil viele bürger
verstehen dass nicht auch die kanzlerin
konnte das in der pressekonferenz nicht
erklären sie sagen konnten uns auch 16
14 20 also mit welcher begründung sagt
die politik 15 kilometer ab stadtgrenze
müssen ist 50 kilometer
höchstgeschwindigkeit in der stadt sein
oder könnten es auf 45 oder 55 sein
sie müssen irgendwann mal eine grenze
festlegen und sie können natürlich bei
jedem grenzwert darüber diskutieren
warum man nicht auch zehn prozent anders
sein könnte ich weiß nur darauf 515
kilometer radius der kirche in bayern
wohlgemerkt ausschließlich für die frage
dass man nicht touristische ausflüge
über 15 kilometer hinaus machen kann
sie können ihre einkäufe machen können
arzt mit und wir kontrollieren wir das
dann der hermann hermann vii viii
kontrollieren sie das dann wie
kontrollieren sie das dann wie muss ich
mir das vorstellen ich bin ich bin wenn
ich in bayern bildung beispiel zum
beispiel wenn jetzt einer in den
bayerischen wald an den arbeiten ausflug
macht oder auch am tegernsee und erfährt
dort zum beispiel mit den kennzeichen
eines landkreises der über die 200er
incidents liegt kommt da an dann wird
die polizei sich von demjenigen der aus
einem solchen landkreis mit über 200
kommt fragen mit denen sich eine aussage
geben lassen warum er denn da unterwegs
ist und was ist wenn er mit einem
mietwagen unterwegs ist was ist mit
einem mietwagen unterwegs ist münchner
kennzeichen dann wird nicht kontrolliert
wird so jemand natürlich stichproben
habt ja auch kontrolliert ich will nur
vor allen dingen noch mal drauf an dass
sie hören schon hermann wie absurd das
ist oder also das ist doch absurd also
wie wird das ganze
das ist doch absurd also wie wird das
ganze am ende machen sie regeln am ende
machen sie regeln in einem richter
präsidentenkonferenz sie müssen diese
ausführen und sie sagen gerade
eigentlich in wahrheit sie können das
gar nicht kontrollieren wieder sie sagen
jetzt okay dann gibt es ein
autokennzeichen vielleicht versuchen wir
dann mal gerade gerade gesagt ich habe
ihn jetzt gerade gesagt dass wie das zum
beispiel was anders für eine kontrolle
sein könnte sie können auch alle
fahrzeuge der auf einem parkplatz stehen
zum beispiel kontrollieren wenn sie
nicht das kennzeichen zum beispiel
dieses entsprechenden landkreises haben
wo man da zu hause ist
die polizei wird das kontrollieren genau
so wie wir auch die nächtliche
ausgangssperre kontrollieren
aber klar ist auch sie reden von den
grundrechts einschränkungen tourismus
wohlgemerkt zum spazierengehen zum
spazieren 15 kilometer fünf bedeutet
radius dass das insgesamt schon mal eine
fläche selbst wenn sie es nur punktuell
vom wohnort aus betrachten von über 700
quadratkilometern sind in der sich immer
noch jeder der arbeit in einer solchen
incident von über 200 infizierten auf
100000 einwohner gerechnet sich befindet
da wonach sich er hat immer noch 700
quadratkilometer in denen es sich frei
bewegen kann in ihrem spazieren gehen
kann und so weiter ein paar gemerkt
wohnort und schule und arztbesuch ist es
sowieso völlig ungehindert also ich
glaube wir brauchen das nicht unter
allzu harten grundrechtseingriffen also
hat palmer sie hören sie können beruhigt
sein wenn sie zum arzt müssen dürfen sie
weiter als 15 kilometer sich entfernen
von ihrer stadtgrenze werden sie diese
15 kilometer regel befolgen
das muss ich nicht in baden württemberg
wird diese regel nicht umsetzen das hat
der ministerpräsident klar angekündigt
habe die verordnung gelesen sie steht
nicht drin und zwar aus einem guten
grund man hat nämlich einen besseren weg
gefunden
in gedser wie mir dieser 15 kilometer
radius des wirkt willkürlich aspect ein
aufbau denkt jetzt was kommt als
nächstes wann ist dann die totale
ausgangssperre
es ist sinnlos ist etwas kontrollieren
die einwände sind ja alle offensichtlich
baden württemberg hat gesagt worum geht
es denn eigentlich uns geht es doch um
diese überfüllten skigebiete wo man
jetzt nicht skifahren war die
mittelgebirge und deswegen wird dort der
zugang gedrosselt über parkplätze
polizei über als polizeibehörden wind es
nötig ist und das auch richtig so
natürlich muss man abstand halten und
darf da nicht in langen schlangen stehen
aber das ist eine sinnvolle treffsichere
maßnahme wir haben diese 15 kilometer
regel einfach nur die leute aufregt und
die akzeptanz der maßnahmen zerstört und
deswegen ist das einer der punkte wo ich
sagte das hätte man in dieser
regierungskonferenz so nicht beschließen
dürfen gerade dann wenn man meint dass
die kontakt beschränkungen in die
verbote der königsweg sind was ich ja
nicht teile ich bin der meinung dass das
schönste risikogruppen der menschen über
65 und effiziente kontakt verfolgung mit
hightech der königsweg wäre das tun wir
aber nicht dann wollen wir wenigstens
nicht auch noch das instrument kontakt
beschränkungen zerstörung in dem man so
widersinnige regelungen trifft bin froh
dass baden württemberg das nicht tut
herr palmer sie sagen das regt die leute
auf und gleich kommen lauterbach denn
ein parteikollege von ihm
lutz trümper der oberbürgermeister von
magdeburg hat sich auch sehr klar
geäußert
ich halte diese ganzen maßen und wenn
man die jetzt beschließt für nicht
administrierbar und auch nicht
kontrollierbar teilnehmer die
drastischen zahlen von heute haben wir
uns für 100 in einer woche das 100 pro
100000 einwohner sind auf 240.000 100
240 leute das ist pro 10.000 einwohner
einer der infiziertes pro 10.000
einwohner einen markt und jetzt wollen
sie die anderen 9999 tage darfst nicht
verlassen ich will das jetzt nicht
kommentieren aber ich finde das sind
alles noch über die man sich gedanken
macht diese haben für mich keine große
bedeutung für mich an bedeutung die
altenheime zu schützen und die schulen
aufzubauen das halte ich für sinnvoll
nicht festzulegen ob 15,4 kilometer 13,3
kilometer jemand sich nicht bewegen kann
das ändert nichts an der infektion
situation gar nichts lauterbach was geht
ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie diese
kritik hören von ihrem parteikollegen
also erstmal
respekt aber die rechnung ist falsch so
die also instruments von 100 also muss
dabei beachten wie lange jemand der sich
interessiert hat durchschnittlich
ansteckend ist und wenn man das dann
recht dazu über den daumen gepeilt dann
bedeutet das dass alle davon 200 bis 1
ist aber erlaubt aber es geht es geht
mir in einer leider war es geht mir in
dem punkt ist ist alles nicht
administrierbar und nicht durchführbar
was da bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
wurde
ja aber ich glaube schon relevant wenn
sich jemand was sich also sagen wir mal
um den faktor 20 berechnet dann ist
vielleicht auch die voraussetzung für
seine empfehlungen nicht so solide als
wenn das richtig gehabt hätte was ich
heute andere wenn ich also werde ich
mich um den faktor 20 verrechnet dann
konnte also die also maßnahmen jahren
oder anderen maßnahmen nicht als
sinnvoll und dann wird es vielleicht
heißen und sich erstmal einarbeiten
ich bin bei uns selbst der meinung das
ist auch wichtig wäre im maßnahmen wenn
man sie gut erklärt zu beschließen sie
jetzt dann wenn sie zugegebener weise
schlecht kontrollierbar sind
das stimmt mich anhängern zu dann muss
man damit leben aber eine maßnahme nur
dann nicht zu beschließen und wenn sie
sinnvoll ist weil ich sie gar nicht
kontrollieren dann aber schlecht
kontrollieren hat kann das werk war sie
auch ein armutszeugnis
sicherlich ist diese 15 kilometer regel
nicht das beste der beschlüsse die
gefasst worden sind ab 15 jahren war
sicherlich nicht wir reden jetzt auch
schon wieder viel zu viel darüber werden
uns momentan bei lauterbad nein da muss
ich dann zwischen lauter was sie sagen
wir reden viel zu viel darüber
das ist eine regel die die menschen
beschäftigt die wurde beschlossen bei
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
da sitzen alle ministerpräsidenten mit
der kanzlerin zusammen und beschließen
dass und sie sagen wir reden zu viel
darüber aber wenn einigen bundesländern
g 20 uhr sollen sich die leute ist daran
halten oder nicht
natürlich aber ich glaube dass es
tatsächlich viel mehr leute gibt sehr
viele leute gibt die sich mit der frage
beschäftigen wie wir eben am anfang
diskutiert haben wie lange soll das
eigentlich gehen und was ist unser ziel
daher fand ich die debatte 50 oder 25
ob das realistisch ist das war eine
inhalts geladene debatte jetzt sucht man
sich den schwächsten punkt der
beschlüsse aus und hakt auf den
beschluss der teilung
ich finde in der öffentlichen debatte
ich habe was ich breche mit sehr vielen
leuten da ist der ein oder andere findet
das unsinnig aber das ist im großen und
ganzen diskutiert wo das sehe ich gar
nicht jeder denkt okay die wollen damit
den tourismus unterbieten und untersagen
nun dafür ist das gemeint und das ist
auch was du nicht nur der tourismus in
die mittelgebirge sondern aller
tourismuspreis tourismus darunter sagt
wird das hat man vielleicht einfach so
ausdrücken können das stimmt mich auch
ein paar dazu dass man das vielleicht in
baden württemberg etwas eleganter zum
ausbau aber die leute kapieren doch was
gemeint
naja wenn es darum geht dass die sendung
wie hast du die richtigen fragen die
richtigen fragen sind was ist unser ziel
wie lange soll das ganze gelten wo er
lauter leute dann muss sie unterbrechen
denn die richtigen fragen die stelle ich
möchte ihm kunst einmal einmal zeigen
was im harz los war wo viele diskutiert
haben und wie die menschen dort mit dem
lockdown umgehen erneut reisten viele
menschen in den harz auch die parkplätze
waren voll
wie die polizei mitteilte wegen
möglicher überfüllung und des
ansteckungsrisikos hinsichtlich der
korona pandemie hatten die behörden
eigentlich vor ausflügen in den
winterlichen harz abgeraten die
eigentlich werden kann man kein spiel
das uns auch nicht einsperren wir fahren
einfach los genießen das haben ganz viel
spaß ich heute wissen einsperren kann
man kein was denken sie
da man kann die menschen in der taten
nicht einsperren das ist auch so dass
der staat nicht wirklich kontrollieren
kann was im privaten wohnräumen passiert
und ich will noch mal klar sagen weil er
hermann haben wir so gespielt hat bei
mir stimmt reden und handeln überein wir
haben diese 15 kilometer grenze in der
rheinland-pfälzischen verordnung auch
nicht umgesetzt weil sie schlichtweg
fällig ist und weil sie nicht
vermittelbar ist
insofern gibt es schon unterschiede wer
regierungsverantwortung hat und ich will
noch mal sagen es ist eine zumutung wenn
sie sich mal anschauen bürgerinnen und
bürger in der stadt berlin oder im land
berlin
wir können quasi dann können sie die ich
möchte gerne ich möchte gerne bei der
frau bleiben die wir dort im beitrag
gezeigt haben können sie verstehen dass
ich mich den gedanken zu ende führen auf
dem land werden die leute quasi in einem
dorf bei zweit auf zwei dörfer
beschränkt das doch unzumutbar und das
führt dazu dass die menschen am ende
ich lehne die maßnahmen ab 530 dann
würden wir wohl größte golf seien bei
ihnen wenn die ich schon bei 15
kilometern begrenzt sind ein dorf 15
kilometer ja ich hätte sie gerne an die
eifel zu kommen da können sich mal
anschauen was für abstände dazwischen
dörfern sind und die denken
offensichtlich nur offensichtlich nur in
großstädtischen strukturen
aber es gibt auch menschen leben auf dem
land und sie können noch nicht sagen es
ist genauso jemand der dort lebt in der
eifel ist so zu behandeln wie jemand in
berlin darf sich dann in berlin im
ganzen bundesland frei bewegen und das
ist infektions technisch oder
infektiologie ist das völlig
unproblematisch aber auf dem land werden
die leute in ihr dorf eingesperrt das
doch verrückt dass das macht keinen sinn
und das akzeptiert und sie brauchen
menschen überzeugen wollen brauchen sie
regeln die sie auch wirklich erklären
können und ich fand das schon schwach wo
sie gesagt haben die 15 kilometer
die hat mal einfach so aus der luft
gegriffen das hat ja dann mit
infektionsschutz nichts zu tun man
reguliert weil man sich offensichtlich
gefällt indem man immer schärfer
registriert das macht keiner richtigen
essen fehlt erklären warum bestimmte
regeln notwendig sind und da gehört vor
allen dingen einsatz um soziale kontakte
die vermeidbar sind müssen vermieden
werden
da brauche ich keine 15 kilometer regel
da brauche ich keine der branche nichts
dafür muss man den leuten erklären
aber das wird findet ja viel zu wenig
statt und nochmal wenn man sagt wir
können nicht lockern weil wir keine
verlässlichen zahlen der feiertage warum
verschärft man dann das kann mir niemand
beantworten können sie auch nicht
beantworten vielleicht versuchen es ist
meine ich kann ihnen nur noch mal sagen
wir haben nach wie vor das problem dass
unsere krankenhäuser randvoll sind und
so viel ich weiß ist dass in rheinland
pfalz zum beispiel auch der fall
wir haben das problem dass wir auf gar
keinen fall eine weitere steigerung der
krankenhausbehandlungen entsprechend im
moment gebrauchen können
dann müssten wir nehmen hier hält
cambridge zu dem punkt dass wir corona
kranken tatsächlich keinen kranken
hermann das haben sie jetzt schon zum
dritten mal gesagt etwas stehen wird ich
muss einem ganz kurz ich möchte ihnen
einmal ein hermann zu ende ich möchte
ihn einmal ein foto gemacht heute in
bayern los war
da sehen sie nämlich wie ist dort beim
schlittschuhlaufen aussah hermann sie
als innenminister scheint mir nicht so
dass sie die kontrolle haben was die
kontakt was die kontakte angeht
wir sehen hier eine menge menschen
aufeinander
die schlittschuhlaufen auf engstem raum
sozusagen wenn sie sagen sie wollen
diese 15 kilometer regel durchsetzen
aber sie haben ja nicht mal das im griff
ich gehe davon aus sie reden von der
situation am nymphenburger kanal hat die
polizei dort die menschen aufgerufen
hier stärkeren abstand zu wahren nachdem
diese freundlichen appelle keine wirkung
getan haben und dann sogar zwei personen
im eis eingebrochen sind hat die polizei
den gesamten kanal geräumt und den kanal
für jeden zugang gesperrt
aber auch hier wohl konkret gehandelt
und den anderen fernsehsendern konnten
sie diese bilder dass der kanal dann
geräumt wurde auch sehen sie sollten
hier bitte auch von seiten ihres senders
hier keine falschen eindruck bei den
schnell machen keinen falschen eindruck
wir haben nun gezeigt dass sie sagen wie
viele menschen sich dort versammelt
haben eine ganze zeit lang konnten sie
sogar sagen sich dort so frau sondern
ihr vorgehalten die polizei die
nein-seite ins gericht ich habe nicht
einen herrmann und den einmal geräumt
er mahnt sie haben sie haben mich nicht
richtig zitiert ich habe nicht über die
polizei gesprochen sondern ich habe
gesagt dass sie ja offenbar das nicht
unterbinden können dass die menschen
sich versammeln herr lauterbach
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie
solche bilder sehen das ist natürlich
gestoßen da muss man sagen man darf das
infektionsrisiko in einer solchen
situation auch nicht unterschätzen weil
die menschen die auf engen miteinander
sprechen und wenn dann mit anderen
spricht auch draußen auf irgendwie
abstand und trägt eine maske fehler da
waren die alten kranken maske dann ist
über die transfer infektion die
infektion durchaus möglich und auch
nicht unwahrscheinlich und außerdem
reist man entweder im auto oder in der
bahn und gerade anreise im auto ist ein
hochrisiko bereich wenn das jetzt sagen
wir ein familienmitglied schon hart wenn
ein familienmitglied schon infiziert ist
dann ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
alle familienmitglieder ich möchte dass
sich aus einer solchen autofahrt dann
interessieren auch deutlich erhöht womit
das ist also gefährlich ich würde es mir
erlauben einen satz doch gar nichts wenn
wir sagen wir zwei mal gesagt werden
die beschlüsse seien geschlossen weil es
obwohl es keine daten gab das ist so
nicht richtig gesehen wo sie müssen sie
müssten es eigentlich besser wissen
wir hatten keine vollständigen daten
weil eben die feiertage drei dinge
überlagert haben wenn man weniger
getestet es wurde weniger berichtet auf
der anderen seite gab es mehr kontakte
daher drei unterschiedlich belgrad
versucht diese drei unterschiedlichen
faktoren zu korrigieren also dafür
herauszurechnen und haben dabei auch
also die zahl der positivsten
herangezogen und die zahle
neuankömmlinge auf die intensiv dass und
zumindest ein riesenunterschied ob ich
sage ich habe weniger daten ich
korrigiere aber dafür mit mathematisch
acker anerkannten verfahren oder ob ich
andeute wir hätten keine daten gehabt
und da das müssen sie besser nach also
was man dass ich mache es jetzt sich
ehrlich ich meine das jetzt nicht äußern
polemik oder was sondern also sind
dürfen nicht den eindruck erwecken wir
hätten also ohne daten gerade das ist
also zu wenig herr lauterbach meint ist
nicht polemisch lauterbach meint das
nicht polemisch deswegen möchte ich eine
polemische frage stellen an herrn kaymer
die menschen machen doch gar nicht mehr
mit oder bei diesen regeln wenn wir uns
das anschauen also wir sehen sie steht
schon laufen die menschen verstehen die
15km regeln nicht sie haben gehört was
der magdeburger oberbürgermeister dort
gesagt hat haben sie das gefühl da hält
sich überhaupt noch irgendjemand daran
ja das habe ich schon die meisten
menschen machen weiterhin mit aber es
steigt halt auch die spannung und die
leute werden zunehmend genervt deswegen
war ja mal eine these wer die akzeptanz
der leute erhalten will der darf solche
struck fehler nicht machen wie die 15
kilometer regel oder was ich viel
schlimmer finde die ein freund regel
weil die leute dann nicht mehr bereit
sind es zu akzeptieren
in meinem umfeld ich habe für ein kind
ist noch nicht mal 15 jahre alt die
familienväter die familien haben gesagt
da machen wir nicht mehr mit diese regel
werden wir dann brechen und zwar
absichtlich weil wir nicht bereits in
unser familienleben zu zerstören zu
lassen und dann erodiert ist und
deswegen bin ich dafür dass man
irgendwann erkannt dass man die schraube
überdreht und stoppt ich glaube wir
können härtere maßnahmen gerade den
familien nicht mehr zumuten ich denke
schon dass wir da wirtschaft noch mehr
zu bieten können weil viele das
home-office nicht nutzen obwohl sie es
könnten da frage ich mich schon warum
man da so zurückhaltend bleibt schließen
der wirtschaft ist ganz falsch aber mehr
home office verlangen das könnte man
schon und ich bin auch nach wie vor der
meinung dass wir uns zu wenig um das
eigentliche risiko kümmern
unter 45 sagt sogar hauptposten ist
corona nicht schlimmer als die krippe
zahlenmäßig das risiko sitzt ganz massiv
bei den über 65-jährigen und dass wir es
nicht schaffen uns auf die zu
konzentrieren das ist das eigentliche
problem wir haben es im übrigen immerhin
geschafft die altenheime ziemlich gut zu
schützen durch ganz engmaschiges testen
da haben wir im september angefangen
andere haben gewartet bis november oder
dezember ich lesen der zeitung das ist
immer noch nicht möglich ist die masken
an die über 65-jährigen die
medizinischen schutzmasken zu verteilen
weil die bons nicht funktioniert haben
und alles viel zu aufwendig ist wir
haben einfach alle anfang november über
65 direkt mit der post versorgt und die
maske dahin geschickt auf kosten der
stadt wissen sie warum machen wir immer
noch strengere regeln bis die leute das
gefühl haben sie dürfen nicht mehr raus
und dann nicht mehr mitmachen statt
unserem die dinge zu kümmern wir uns
wirklich voranbringen und die
intensivstation entlassen das ist das
schönste über 65 irgendwer muss jetzt in
den vordergrund gerückt werden einfach
mal ganz kurz
dazu noch sie waren darf ich mitte
dezember auch gast bei uns in der
sendung mit peter altmaier oder haben
wir darüber gesprochen auch über den
schutz der alten und der alte mann
eigentlich gesagt natürlich treffe ich
mich gerne mal mit herrn palma und
vielleicht kommt ja auch mal ins
kabinett wurden sie eingeladen von der
kanzlerin mal zu erklären wie man die
alten schützt nein ich habe ihn ja schon
damals gesagt dass ich diese einladung
nicht erwarte das ist auch nicht das
thema über das wir jetzt sprechen
herr hermann warum schützen wir die
alten nicht besser das ist glaube ich
die große frage auch in diesen tagen
insgesamt wenn wir uns die statistiken
anschauen sind wir mittlerweile bei den
bei der toten anzahl teilweise sogar
über den usa das ist doch beschämend für
deutschland
also ich stimme zu dass der schutz der
älteren bevölkerung mir ganz ganz
besonderen schwerpunkt bilden muss das
steht übrigens auch ausdrücklichen
beschluss der ministerpräsidenten drin
dass dadurch andere schwerpunkte gesetzt
wird und wir müssen uns in der tat auch
klar darüber sein dass jedenfalls nach
dem bayerischen zahlen aber es ist auf
bundesebene nicht sehr viel anders
das etwa zwei drittel aller verstorbenen
der seit februar märz letzten jahres der
aller die an corona damit koma gestorben
sind in der tat über 80 jahre alt sind
das ist die hauptzielgruppe bei der es
darum geht wenn wir vor allen dingen die
sterbezahlen in grenzen halten wollen
deshalb haben wir hier auch spezielle
maßnahmen zum beispiel eingeleitet das
testen was er palma gerade zurecht
angesprochen hat konsequent in den
einrichtungen
dass sie aber auch festgelegt haben es
darf nur noch ein besucher in ein
solches heim der sich unmittelbar vorher
hat testen lassen der negativ getestet
ist um auszuschließen dass von außen her
ständig neu ein virus eingebracht wird
denn das eine ist das personal in diesen
heimen das andere sind eben die besucher
wir wollen nicht
diese kontakte völlig verbieten aber wir
haben leider immer wieder die erfahrung
gemacht dass immer wieder von personen
die vielleicht selbst noch nicht gemerkt
haben dass sie selbst auch infiziert
haben die dann einen alten menschen
besucht haben in solchen heimen
das durch die einen virus immer wieder
in die heime eingetragen worden ist
deshalb jetzt konsequente kontrolle
es wird nur noch ein besucher
eingelassen der vorher sichert testen
lassen
ebenso auch in den krankenhäusern und
das sind denke ich ganz wichtige
maßnahmen das sind nur die reichen noch
vielleicht nicht alle aus aber dieses
konsequent zu vollziehen wird sicherlich
dazu beitragen
hier die gefahren zu reduzieren und das
andere ist dass gerade diese zielgruppe
die über 80-jährigen diejenigen sind die
jetzt geimpft werden und zwar die in den
heimen als allererste und ich hoffe sehr
dass wenn diese impfungen jetzt ihre
wirkung tun nicht glaube dass wir die
betroffenen in den heimen bereits
innerhalb der nächsten zwei wochen die
impfungen abschließen können dann sind
schon mal alle
80 in den heimen entsprechend geimpft
dass dies dann hoffentlich stand auch
eine unmittelbare wirkung hat auf die
frage wie viele in diesen heimen stärken
deshalb ganz klar ja das ist ein
hauptschwerpunkt unserer aktuellen
arbeit noch eine frage an sie herr
herrmann absatz von der debatte um die
alten um die totenzahlen hat auch markus
söder der bayerische ministerpräsident
in diesen tagen für aufregung gesorgt
als er von einer corona raf gesprochen
hat die uns droht sie als innenminister
was haben sie für erkenntnisse wie nah
sind wir an einer cola raf wir müssen
sehen dass gerade was sich in dieser
woche am sogenannten d day 2.0 getan hat
die versuche hier autobahnen
stillzulegen auch übrigens angriffe auf
bundes- bahnstrecken dass hier erstmals
aus teilen dieser sogenannten querdenken
bewegung massive eingriffe angriffe auf
den straßen sagt er und den
eisenbahnverkehr stattgefunden haben und
das wohlgemerkt in einer konzertierten
aktion quer durch verschiedene
bundesländer
das ist eine massive eskalation im
vergleich zu dem was bisher geredet
haben nämlich das querdenken demos
veranstaltet haben und wir uns zu recht
darüber aufgeregt haben dass die keinen
abstand eingehalten haben und dass die
keine masken tragen wollten aber jetzt
völlig unabhängig von solchen demos für
zu versuchen autobahnen zu blockieren
auf den eisenbahnverkehr einzuwirken
das ist schon eine massive eskalation
und deshalb ist es dringend notwendig
dass wir sehr genau beobachten was tut
sich da eigentlich mit in diesem bereich
der die die 2.0 bewegung das ist ein
teil dieser querdenker
ich will die nicht alle querdenker damit
identifizieren aber da entwickelt sich
wirklich ein hochgefährliches potenzial
und es gibt darüber hinaus den teil der
querdenker der ganz offen auch mit
rechtsradikalen kooperiert das ist auch
nicht typisch für alle querdenker aber
so einen teil der querdenker und es gibt
den versuch der rechtsradikalen hier
einfluss zu gewinnen und auch damit muss
sie
der verfassungsschutz natürlich
beschäftigt herr lauterbach mit der
bitte um kurze antwort sehen sie die
gefahr auch der korona ich glaube da hat
herr herrmann rechts das muss im auge
behalten also wir sehen dass sich rechte
gruppen ohren die querdenker also
zusammen tun und sonst nichts
radikalisiert das sehen wir insbesondere
den vereinigten staaten aber nicht nur
dort somit also stimme ich herrn aber zu
dann muss man früh genau beobachten und
eingreifen und das auch dann auch keinen
verteilen lassen ja ich möchte jetzt zu
einer debatte kommen die uns in den
vergangenen tagen wochen eigentlich am
meisten beschäftigt hat muss man sagen
und das ist das thema impfen und die
frage ob wir in deutschland genügend
impfstoff haben welche fehler dort
gemacht wurden und in diesem
zusammenhang möchte ich sprechen mit dem
schauspieler ralf möller
der nämlich probleme hat wie viele
deutsche nämlich er kommt nicht an einen
impfstoff für seine mutter herr müller
schönen guten abend erzählen sie uns
einmal etwas über ihre persönliche
impfstoff odyssee
na ja das ganze fing ja ich lebe hier in
los angeles überwiegend bitter aber oft
auch hier meine eltern hier
recklinghausen wohnen bei mir im haus
und vater wird jetzt 290 mutter 85 40
februar
und wie alle hat ja auch schon im
lockeren sommer das ist dort impfstoffe
in zukunft gehen wird und dann
verfestigte sich das ganze natürlich
dann auch zum herbst besonders zum
oktober
ich sagte dann auch mutter weiß was ich
bleib nicht nur silvester nicht nur
weihnachten sondern auch silvester und
dann in der ersten woche steht ja drin
ihr seid die ersten 80 85 bis 90 der
vater kommt ihr dann dran natürlich auch
pflegepersonal ärzte und alles ist olga
ich das sieht gut aus wir wussten auch
aha bis zu 95 oder paarweise 98 prozent
sind die werte der verschiedenen
impfstoffe alle auch gut
und dann dachte ich mir naja jetzt ruft
aber immer die nummer an die überall im
radio hörst und sie ist
da wurde ich oben wohl aus sachsen
verlegt und da wiederum wurde ich dann
wieder nach düsseldorf klar ich komme
aus nordlandes phase weil auch und ist
ja aber wann kann ich denn mit den
eltern zur impfung
und wir haben ja schon das zählt hier
ganz riesig große in recklinghausen da
steht schon seit wochen wann geht das
los und dann sagte ich mir immer das
wird wohl sie bekommen bescheid ist auch
wann
naja ende januar anfang februar ja ich
sah wie sollen alte menschen das denn
ich bin es im moment da wir haben ja
auch nachbarn sind alt wie soll so an
wie sein alter frauen im internet sich
anmelden
wie soll das alles vonstatten gehen ist
es dann soweit ist sind wir bei ende
februar anfang märz
wer mal hast du das leiden die haben
nicht genügend impfstoff ist ein moment
biotech wir sind die firma wir haben das
mit fischer zusammen entwickelt
warum sie nicht genügend impfstoff ja
fragen sie mal einen gesundheitsminister
hat wahrscheinlich gestellt dann sagte
ich mir noch naja gut europäische
gemeinschaft alles muss auch
zusammenhalten könnte ich die
ellbogengesellschaft haben aber ich
sagte mir so als gesundheitsminister
rufst du die anderen minister unten alle
an und so hammer wie viel brauchen wir
denn für die alten und für die pfleger
und erste wenigstens dann hörte ich so
die zahl acht bis neun millionen gut das
ist nur zahl dann schaue ich weiter dass
bayern und nrw die effektivsten höchsten
raten haben und das ist wie der andere
andere bundesländer gibt wo es eben halt
weniger der fall ist herr müller wie wir
haben mal ganz kurz wie haben ihre
eltern darauf reagiert dass es dann kein
impfstoff gab obwohl sie ja in einem
alter sind wo es den schnell geben
sollte
naja die eltern sind relativ hier im
moment nur sicher weil auch wenn jemand
kommt immer nur mit maske es kommen
weniger leute ihre ins haus und ich
wurde auch schon gesagt dann schon mal
essen und kümmere mich da also im moment
sind sie noch sicher aber ich habe
natürlich bekannte und freunde auch die
mittlerweile auch jünger sind und auf
intensivstationen gelegen haben und noch
heute nach monaten dessen noch immer
davon in mitleidenschaft gezogen sind
herzlichen dank haben wir nicht nur
sagen ja ja ja bitte
ich sage es war so wie ich zum beispiel
sagen jetzt gut auf die ganze politik da
wird viel gemacht
ich muss übrigens immer lauter bauen
auch sagen der wird normalerweise die
goldmedaille kriegen das ist ja ein
marathon was der mann in den letzten
monaten gesprochen gemacht und getan hat
und wirklich toll dass ich auch da
dementsprechend für einsetzt ich muss
einfach sagen dass wir nicht als
verantwortlicher minister
nicht fähig bin diese sachen zu
koordinieren
dann gehöre ich gar nicht absehen da
fällt jetzt schon um der jens spahn
gehören ich will dich auf ihn schimpfen
aber dann stimmt irgendwas nicht dann
gehört man da nicht hin wenn wir das
nicht kann ich habe noch bei euch in der
bild gelesen an erster stelle und als
kanzlerkandidat leute wir sind so weit
entfernt wie wären wahrscheinlich bis
mai oder juni
ich schätze meine nächsten vier monaten
noch in den walk down sein
ihr seht doch die zahlen ihr seht doch
was da entfernungen ist dann heißt es
wieder schulen und kids com wieder jetzt
eher sind werden wir da in der
resolution habe gelogen absolut haben
wir immer nur ganz kurz ganz konkret bei
ihren eltern bleiben und herrn
lauterbach fragen jetzt wo er müller ihn
schon die goldmedaille verleihen will
herr lauterbach was raten sie den eltern
von reifen müller wie kommen sie jetzt
an diesen impfstoff also wichtige
nachricht ich sind momente in nordrhein
westfalen wie ist nicht in den
pflegeheimen daten daher die meisten
szenen so sind noch überhaupt nicht in
betrieb und die einfach sie sich an der
miezen besorgen ist in dem man die 116
das geht nicht das ist da beißt sich die
katze immer wieder entspannt das
funktioniert nicht
ich habe es mehrfach ausprobiert weil
ich jetzt gerade nützel mal in den
verschiedenen sendungen bin ich bin
morgen mit dpa ich bin mit dem stern und
den spiegeln ja gut dass sie gut dass
sie früher mal wirkende müller ich habe
keine politischen interessen ich möchte
kein kanzler werden ich muss auch nix
rücksicht nehmen sie wahrscheinlich dass
auch nicht außer natürlich die partei
aber das ist so eine miss organist als
ich komme wie offene titanic chor wieder
suchte rettungsboot und das schiefgeht
langsam unter wir sehen wir sind wir
hätten locker war sind wir sind hier auf
der digital menschenbild und keiner
macht nichts das ist im februar nicht
vorbei das wissen sie auch und das
wissen auch die politiker dass das ganze
noch spätestens bis april mindestens
gewinn wird wenn ich vermeiden
was haben wir noch wir haben doch die
schwerste zeit vor uns herr lauterbach
sind wir auf einer titanic funktioniert
gar nichts und hat eher spaß schon
erstmalig sind nicht auf der titanic das
wird
in der tat das habe ich auch gesagt über
den januar weg dauert werden nichts
angeht im ersten tenor aus dem läuft da
rauskommen das unmöglich das halte ich
auch nicht bedenkt dass wir den leuten
noch nicht sagen
zum 2 ich halte dich hier aus jeder
partei zusammen polemik heraus hat er
mir auch dass jetzt leicht machen können
hätte gesagt dass er in nrw die aus dem
schwarz gelbe regierung schafft das
nicht aber es ist tatsächlich so an
einigen orten gibt es dann hart und
wiederum nicht zum beispiel in diesem
landkreis wo meine mutter lebt ist auch
wie wird jetzt 86 das funktioniert die
116 117 an anderen stellen funktioniert
es nicht was muss dringend verbessert
werden also ich stimme herrn aller ohne
wenn und aber zu
das lustig sein und zwar in ganz
deutschland das gleiche verfahren und
das muss auch das musste jetzt auch
sicherlich gesagt dass unter der 116 117
deutschland war immer leute erreichbar
sind das muss dann ausgegliedert werden
dann kommt das müsste immer jemand da
herr palmer r palmersheimer funktioniert
die nummer bei ihnen 116 117 und wie
würde es den eltern von ralf möller in
tübingen gehen
wir haben in tübingen land im zentrum in
betrieb werden januar hat der betrieb
gestartet allerdings mit im moment noch
mit drei von 18 sogenannten impfstraßen
also wenn mehr impfstoff kommt können
wir sechsmal mehr leute pro tag sind
aber so etwa 300 kommen derzeit jeden
tag
und die haben ihren termin auch über die
einzelnen 6117 kommen
ich glaube wir müssen hier unterscheiden
zwischen den glücklichen die halt lange
genug in der warteschleife gewesen sind
und wo die kinder sich trauen die haben
wir ja das macht die kriegen ihren slot
aber viele andere scheitern natürlich
tragen und im moment scheint mehr als
erfolgreich sind weil wir nicht genügend
impfstoff haben ich glaube das kann man
im moment nicht auflösen den impfstoff
kann man nicht backen der muss
produziert werden mehr als wir geliefert
bekommen können wir nicht vergessen und
deswegen das inhalt viele dann erfolglos
bei der suche nach dem impftermin dann
müssen wir die nächsten drei wochen noch
durch wir sind wer hat schuld an diesem
desaster ist das wirklich wir haben da
sagt dann insbesondere herr sparen ist
es die bundeskanzlerin und was kannst du
also das nächste mal ist es ja nicht
ungewöhnlich dass wenn so eine massen
aktion startet das das am anfang ruckelt
also ich finde wir müssen auch fair sein
wo man jetzt eher wissen jetzt ein
halbes jahr ein
das war sogar noch etwas schon so doch
vorerst ist so ehrlich zu wenig
impfstoff verfügbar ist die impfzentren
laufen nicht auf volllast weil zu wenig
impfstoff verfügbar ist und er in den
letzten jahren geht der saas markt räumt
weil die lotsen tanja alle 28 tage in
amerika die ganze 500 millionen
aufgekauft gehen alle nach amerika ging
zweimal rama täglich alle sachen drüber
nach
das kritisiere ich ja auch ich finde es
nicht richtig dass die bundesregierung
nicht ergänzen zugekauft hat das diesen
kurs hat sie jetzt geändert nachdem wir
sie heftig dafür kritisiert haben aber
vorausschauende politik hätte anders
ausgesehen und die bundesregierung
verlangt gemeinsam auch mit den
landesregierungen den bürgerinnen und
bürgern enorm viel ab in dieser pandemie
und dieses virus ist in der tat für die
menschen ab 65 insbesondere sehr
gefährlich und man hätte dann auch
erwarten müssen dass die bundesregierung
selbst maximale sorgfalt fährt und dass
sie alles was sie kriegen kann dann im
stoff auch aufkauft aber man hat
offensichtlich sich auf die europäische
union verlassen und dort war am anfang
für die verträge zu wenig geld zur
verfügung gewesen und das ist ja nicht
nachvollziehbar dass ein impfstoff der
in deutschland entwickelt und
hergestellt wird in amerika und in
israel zur verfügung steht auch in
großbritannien
aber bei uns eben nur ein sehr
eingeschränkter menge das er hermann ter
mate hermann warum warum sie in der
bundesregierung zu wenig impfstoff
besorgt
die genauen abläufe hier zwischen eu und
bund waren kann ich nicht beurteilen ich
finde es toll dass wir überhaupt jetzt
einen impfstoff haben denn das hat es in
der medizin geschichte noch nie gegeben
dass für ein neues virus so schnell ein
impfstoff überhaupt entwickelt worden
ist und jetzt
steht es gab hier letztlich situation
dass noch vor drei monaten keineswegs
absehbar war
welcher impfstoff denn als erster
zugelassen werden kann welche firma
sozusagen dann tatsächlich liefern kann
da gab aber das stimmt ja nicht
herrmann das sind ja das stimmt das
stimmt einfach nicht dass es gab in
einem monat wo fest stand dass bei und
tag eben einen impfstoff hat er
funktioniert da haben die usa
großbritannien und israel nachbestellt
und wir nicht und das ist ein fakt ist
ja in ordnung ist im moment ist ja der
der impfstoff von bayern keck ist ja der
einzige der im moment ausgeliefert
worden
aber sie behaupten man konnte nicht die
ernte nicht wissen konnte nicht wissen
wann welcher impfstoff funktioniert das
stimmt einfach nicht
es ist schön dass sie so schallt sind
aber sie wenn sie mal zeitungsartikel
aus der zeit lesen dann gab es ganz
andere firmen die wo damals behauptet
wurde von fachleuten von ich bin keiner
wahr mache ich mir nicht an reichlich
aber wo andere firmen sehr wohl
sozusagen die nase vorn hatten in der
prognose wer bringt als erster den
impfstoff aus lauterbach mit dem fenster
lauterbach wir werden gegen im stoff den
wir kriegen können wir auch weiter
beschaffen
tatsache ist jedenfalls dass will ich im
hinblick auf die dinge was herr müller
gesagt hat sagen wir haben jedenfalls
bei uns eine klare festlegung getroffen
das als erstes die 80-jährigen die über
80-jährigen in den pflegeheimen geimpft
werden das personal in dem pflegeheim
und das personal in den krankenhäusern
jedenfalls die in den intensivstationen
die haben den vorrang brauche es dann
eine impfpflicht herrmann
wir haben das design der impfpflicht
weil wir hören zum beispiel immer mehr
fälle dass pfleger sich gar nicht impfen
und vor allem wir haben jetzt erlebt
heute die bild am sonntag in ihrer
titelgeschichte über einen zahnarzt der
gesagt hat entweder die leute die in
meiner praxis arbeiten impfen sich oder
sie kriegen kein gehalt mehr ist das
nicht vielleicht dann der richtige
schritt
es wird auf jeden fall keine staatliche
impfpflicht geben wenn ein arbeitgeber
beispielsweise sagt ich will dass da
meine leute sich impfen lassen muss er
das mit seinen mitarbeitern selbst
ausmachen
ich höre sehr wohl dass zum beispiel
auch krankenhäuser darüber diskutieren
das jedenfalls auf ihren
intensivstationen nur noch personal
einsetzen dass sie hat ihn verlassen
das sind dinge die im einzelfall konkret
entsprechend vorangebracht werden
müssten ich will damit nur sagen wir
werden in den nächsten tagen wohl jetzt
dann soweit sein in bayern dass wir
jetzt dann auch mit den impfungen von
über 80 jährigen außerhalb der heimat
beginnen können und entsprechend werden
die termine jetzt in den nächsten tagen
vergeben
natürlich wird das dann bis alle über 80
jährigen dürfte noch eine weile dauern
länger wird es dauern als in israel und
großbritannien zum beispiel werden wir
sind einfach da machen wir so oder
hermann
wir sind einfach aber wir sind viel
langsamer als alles andere auf der welt
also entschuldigung es ist doch jetzt
wirklich entschuldigung wenn ich da
jetzt wirklich sehr direkt werde
wirklich schaut du bist zeugin schauen
sie wahl in großbritannien haben die
jetzt über 81.000 tote tier aber das
ändert nichts daran dass die schnell an
impfstoff die politik nein sie können
nicht ernsthaft erzählen dass die korona
politik der britischen regierung um
einen deut besser wäre es haben sich ja
auch gar nicht gesagt ja ich habe mir
nur gesagt dass großbritannien schneller
impfen ist und das können sie in jeder
statistik nachlesen ja und jetzt schauen
sie sich mal an wie es im moment in den
britischen krankenkassen
das ist ja nicht meine frage jetzt
kommen die schon zum 5 andere
krankenhäuser nicht so einen unsinn als
in cannes und großbritannien in
irgendeiner weise höchste wäre als bei
uns tue ich nicht herankomme weiter
geimpft wie wir werden konsequent
versuchen so schnell wie möglich jeden
impfstoff den wir kriegen können
entsprechend einzusetzen da kommt jetzt
dann auch der von der firma moderne auf
bemerkte und bewährten mit dem impfen
konsequent vorangehen hermann wenn sie
herr herr palmer wenn sie hören was er
hermann sagt zum impfstoff
was ist ihr gedanke ich glaube es ist
unmöglich die fehler der vergangenheit
durch gespräche zu ändern damit müssen
wir jetzt klarkommen wir haben nicht
mehr in stoff als wir haben und nach
vorne geblickt müssen wir zusehen dass
wir möglichst schnell die impfstoffe
die wirken auch zu lassen da bin ich
daran dass die ganze rna technologie
über die wir reden weil bionic und
moderner in tübingen erfunden worden ist
und dass dieser weg in tübingen auch
einen impfstoff bereits produziert seit
vielen monaten der in großer zahl
vorrätig ist
jetzt kommt es darauf an den möglichst
schnell zu lassen damit wir ihn
verkaufen können wir müssen nach vorne
blicken und zu sehen dass möglichst
wenig bürokratie dem im weg steht und
dass er möglichst schnell die über
65-jährigen geimpft bekommen denn dann
können wir den lok tor nach meiner
überzeugung beenden
die über 65-jährigen in großer zahl
geimpft sind besteht für die
intensivstation keine gefahr der
überlastung werden nach vorne blicken
herr lauterbach im pflicht ist das etwas
worüber man diskutieren muss zumindest
zum beispiel bei beamten bei politischen
personal und die frage was denken sie
über den zahnarzt den praxis schärfte
gesagt hat also entweder durch oder ihr
braucht bei mir nicht mehr arbeiten oder
zumindest kritik eingehalten werden weil
diese zahlen sollte man sich wirklich
überlegen ob man da arbeiten will und
die fachkräfte die zahlen erst sollte
tätig sind sind ja also gesucht also es
gibt einen enormen mangel an fachkräften
für zahnarztpraxen und vielleicht sind
diese leute dann tatsächlich gut beraten
also sich an anderen arbeitgeber zu
suchen pflicht da so ist nur zu sagen
also die impfpflicht wird nicht kommen
das haben wir zugesagt politik daran
müssen wir uns halten es gibt keine
gründe für eine ähnlich wir werden über
viele monate also bis ende juni zu jedem
gegebenen zeitpunkt mehr impfwillige
haben als im stoff somit wozu braucht
man dann an wenn man sowieso nicht genug
impfstoff hat musst du dann eine frist
das ist abwegig und übrigens für die
risiko berufe ich bin ganz sicher
die allermeisten in der pflege die
werden mit einer verzögerung wenn der
impfstoff da angeboten ist sie werden
sich auch für die impfung entscheiden da
bin ich sicher
würden sie mir gestanden dass ich nur an
was zur aufklärung sage wie es zu dieser
knappheit gekommen ist das ist das thema
jetzt also beendet dann dann würde ich
nichts sagen dass doch das interessiert
und weil sie ja gerade auch mit dem kopf
geschüttelt habe als er hermann
ausgeführt hat
also zunächst einmal ich will mir ja ein
paar an dazu dass es nichts bringt also
dass jetzt wohl zu beklagen aber es ist
trotzdem für die bevölkerung natürlich
wichtig ungefähr zu wissen was gewesen
ist wie das passiert ist
ich halte die also entscheidung also
dass die eu den nimmst auf allen kopf
wie halte ich grundsätzlich nicht für
falsch sondern es richtig gewesen das
ist richtig gewesen aber tatsächlich hat
man dann aus der eu so gut ein paar
fehler gemacht der wichtigste fehler war
dass man mit viel zu wenig geld
verhandelt hat also mit insgesamt 2,7
milliarden euro in amerika sind zwölf
milliarden dollar eingesetzt worden die
uns natürlich viel größer und man hat zu
wenig aus geld in der hand ab zum
zweiten mal hatte ich doch verdacht
gekauft sondern auf beweis gekauft das
heißt die verträge wurden erst gemacht
zu dem zeitpunkt wo die fällen bewiesen
hatten dass sie wirken die amerikaner
und viele andere anfangsverdacht gekauft
nach dem motto wir kaufen von allen im
stoßen so viel wenn nur einer
erfolgreich ist dann haben wir von dem
genug dass damit die bevölkerung in sind
können das wäre in anbetracht der
geringen kosten von impfstoffen die
bessere strategie gewesen und das dritte
problem war in den verträgen steht drin
dass die länder nicht bilateral zu
kaufen können auch wenn sie wollen bis
die verträge unterschrieben sind und es
waren bei und tag erst am 11 11
der fall und also bei modernen
fünfundzwanzigster hälfte des bis dahin
war gab es eine selbstverpflichtung
aller länder die daran gebunden waren
dass sie sich keinen zusätzlichen
impfstoff kaufen konnten
und in der zeit haben sich hat england
israel die amerikaner bedient so ist das
gelaufen
das ist jetzt so sahen die aufklärung
was also bringt es nichts sich daran
festzuhalten aber tatsächlich also wir
müssen jetzt den vollen blick behält
sich auch strategien anzubieten
das ist zum beispiel für richtig ist die
erste ebenso es ist in den vordergrund
zu stellen und ich zweite impfdosis
piontek zumindest erst nach zwölf wochen
zu geben das würde die impf
geschwindigkeit für die nächsten drei
monate verdoppelt das wäre ein riesen
unterschied es macht einen unterschied
ob ich 5 millionen
das war einmal in voll oder 10 millionen
dann ein paar insel
ich rette mit dem einmal im hirn von
10.000.000 vielen der menschen und wir
hoffen wir hoffen dass es mit dem impfen
jetzt schneller geht ganz zum abschluss
möchte ich einmal noch über ein thema
sprechen dass viele viele menschen
beschäftigt und das ist das thema
schulen und darüber haben wir kurz vor
der sendung mit baden-württembergs
kultusministerin und spitzenkandidatin
für die nächste wahl vor allem
angesprochen
nein es halt ich persönlich für schlicht
undenkbar weil bildung und betreuung
muss auch perspektiven der pandemie
haben deshalb und über kitas und
grundschulen gilt es noch mal ganz
besonders ich bin übrigens generell der
meinung dass es jetzt heute zu früh ist
schon darüber zu sprechen was im februar
ist das für mich nicht nachvollziehbar
wir müssen doch erstmal abwarten ob die
verschärften maßnahmen wirken und wie
sie wirken und dann in dem nächsten
schritt bewerten und entscheiden aber
jetzt schon zu sagen wir machen alles
die weiteren monate dicht dafür fehlt
mir momentan der ansatz und eines halte
ich auch für zwingend dass man nicht
pauschal spricht alles weiter zuzulassen
sondern man sich dann auch analog
immerzu infektionszahlen überlegt was
kann man den schrittweise wieder öffnen
und nicht in dieser pauschalität jetzt
schon sagt alles bleibt noch über monate
dicht
naja man schulen aufmachen oder nicht
ich hoffe sehr dass wir anfang februar
wieder wenigstens teilweise
präsenzunterricht einführen können wir
haben deswegen auch schon beschlossen
dass wir die faschingsferien ausfallen
lassen
danach sehen jetzt schon lange genug
schulfrei war und wir damit wirklich wie
ich hoffe im februar mit entsprechend
präsenz unterricht wieder beginnen
können apa sie haben über die
folgeschäden schon gesprochen die
entstehen
sicherlich auch bei unseren kindern die
nicht zur schule gehen können
was denken sie kann man die schulen
jetzt direkt wieder öffnen oder müssen
sie zu bleiben ich halte das was
baden-württemberg ja vorher richtig es
soll ja am 18
januar also in einer woche
weder mit einer teilöffnung begonnen
werden das heißt die grundschulen sollen
wieder präsenzunterricht an da
funktioniert ist das video unterricht
ich ehrlicherweise nicht wirklich und
dann soll es wechsel unterricht geben
und video unterricht statt die höheren
klassen das vernünftig auch die
wiederöffnung der kitas finde ich
richtig denn wir wissen die kinder und
die jugendlichen sind von corona nicht
wirklich bedroht wird die ist
straßenverkehr genauso gefährlich
und aus dem grund ist es ja nun indirekt
dass schutz wiederum für die älteren
wenn wir die schulen und die kitas so
machen familien und kinder dürfen aber
nicht die hauptlast da kann die
betreuung tragen
deswegen müssen wir diese bereiche
wieder kontrolliert öffne und ich glaube
dass das vertretbar ist weil die
intensivstation nicht mit kindern und
jugendlichen belegt werden sondern mit
über 65 jährigen deswegen muss der
schutz dort einsetzen und nicht ihn
direkt bei den schulen und den kindern
eher lauter war kinder und jugendliche
sind weniger betroffen sagte palmer
dann kann man die schulen darauf machen
nein wir müssen den kontaktlosen und er
ist heute wieder richtig wurde ihr von
der eth zürich gezeigt dass neben der
begrenzung auf fünf personen für private
treffen die schulschließungen und auch
die schließung der gastronomie und der
nicht so notwendigen geschäfte aus dem
geschäft machen sich für den täglichen
gebrauch benötigt wie zum beispiel also
lebensmittel legen dass das die
maßnahmen sind die die kontakte am
stärksten reduziert haben die starke
kontakt reduzierung ist der schlüssel
dafür dass wir die kontrolle nur einer
gewinnen
ja also hier also kann sich auch eine
ganz bekehre sieht was ich wäre es noch
mal auch ganz klar werden wir hier sagen
wir mal zurück
früh lockern oder die illusion verfolgen
wir könnten die über 65-jährigen sind
das sind 15 millionen leute für diese 15
millionen leute haben wir für die
nächsten vier monate haben wir nicht
genug impfstoff für die nächsten fünf
monate haben wenn ich selbst auch das
heißt wir können diese leute durch die
impfung nicht schützen
und im übrigen ist es auch so ich warne
davor wenn dich die fatale explodieren
lassen
dann ist es quasi sicher dass wir eine
viel gefährlichere variante nämlich
diese bei 117 variante aus england
bekommen dann bekommen wir noch mal eine
ganz andere lage uns
wetten dass ist mir sehr wichtig ist
seine naive vorstellung zugaben ko und
corona tötet nur oder man ist wieder
gesund
die wichtigsten studien so
langzeitbeobachtung von menschen die
sich einmal mit schweren aufgaben im
krankenhaus gewesen sind ist in china
gemacht wurden hat man jetzt sechs
monate verfolgt was wird aus denjenigen
die sechs monate vorher die krankheit
gehabt haben in dem krankenhaus waren
nicht alle beatmet nicht die schwersten
fälle
die leute waren im durchschnitt 57
jahren alt 75 prozent derjenigen die
wegen corona krankenhaus gewesen sind
waren ein halbes jahr später nicht
gesund und viele von denen werden alles
dann kürzere lebenserwartung haben
wir sehen ja jetzt nur die toten wie
heute sterben die älteren die den weg in
und um die stadt und jetzt aber die
bleiben denn hier nur einsatz dort nur
eine erlaubnis in den einsatz diejenigen
die bleibende nierenschäden hatten oder
bleiben herz- oder plagen den orient wir
werden auch an corona früher sterben nur
dieser tod ist aufgeschoben aber deren
lebenserwartung wird deutlich reduziert
sein und die verlieren zum teil mehr
lebensjahre 80 85 jährigen die jetzt
sterben
herr wissing mit der bitte um eine
schnelle antwort weil wir nicht genug
impfstoff haben bleiben die schulen die
ich habe ich das richtig verstanden
ja das ist ja klar zum ausdruck gekommen
deswegen können wir auch nicht einfach
sagen es war ein fehler dass zu wenig
impfstoff bestellt worden ist aber dann
machen wir ein haken dran sondern wir
haben jetzt eine schwierige situation
weil nicht sorgfältig genug impfstoff
bestellt worden ist und man hätte es in
der tat so machen müssen dass man auf
risiko bei allen bestellt um am ende mit
sicherheit ausreichend impfstoff zur
verfügung zu haben das sagen ja auch
wissenschaftler beispielsweise frau
professor zieht von der leopoldina und
deswegen ist es schon sehr ärgerlich
dass die bundesregierung hier nicht
stärker darauf geachtet hat dass auf
europäischer ebene sorgfältig geordert
wird ich halte es für richtig dass auch
europäisch zu organisieren aber zu sagen
wir geben es nach europa starten aber
europa nicht finanziell ausreichend aus
und erklären gleichzeitig wir
verpflichten uns selber keinen impfstoff
zu bestellen das ist das was man als
jurist als sorgfaltswidrig bezeichnet
und solche fehler hätten der
bundesregierung in dieser pandemie nicht
passieren dürfen jetzt müssen wir mit
dieser situation leben und ich finde es
äußerst bedauerlich dass aufgrund der
fehler der bundesregierung schulen
länger geschlossen bleiben müssen als
nötig weil sie alle so was uns viele
sprechen da muss ich klar widersprechen
wissen sie wissen es besser sie wissen
ganz genau wissen wir jetzt spielen wir
im stoff hätten wären wir in dem lokal
in dem wir derzeit werten den impfstoff
nicht auf so früh bekommen das sagte und
mit dem stoff denn jetzt läuft und nach
werden das ist einfach so nicht richtig
dass die impfzentren jetzt nicht in
volllast fahren weil nicht genügend
impfstoff zur verfügung steht so einfach
können sie aber das letzte alte gilt im
loch da und nichts geändert wir werden
in den ferien bleibt doch dann in dem
ersten schock volllast fahren und wir
kämen schneller mit der durchimpfung der
bevölkerung voran
so einfach können sie sich nicht machen
die bundesregierung hat zu wenig
nachdruck in aufgelegt impfstoff zu
beschaffen
und deswegen werden wir die bekämpfung
mit verzögerungen rechnen müssen und das
bedeutet lockdown verlängerung noch
einmal in trister hermann sie haben mit
dem kopf geschüttelt
also klar ist jedenfalls da hat er
lauterbach recht auch die entscheidung
dass wir jetzt den locker und weiter
brauchen hätte mehr impfstoffe in den
letzten fünf tagen sicherlich keine
auswirkungen gehabt bei der frage wie
bekommen der im februar wie kommen wir
märz im april weiter da wird die frage
wie viel impfstoff steht zur verfügung
und wie viel haben wir ein bis dahin
schon geimpft natürlich eine rolle
spielen
und darum müssen wir jetzt alle chancen
nutzen noch mehr impfstoff zu bekommen
dann dann hoffen wir dass das ganze
schnell passiert ich über ziele
gnadenlos wie einst thomas gottschalk
bei wetten dass deswegen ganz schnelle
runde ballmer nächste woche
cdu-parteitag bitte um schnelle antwort
wen wünschen sie sich als cdu
vorsitzenden und dann vielleicht
kanzlerkandidaten
es ist ja nicht weihnachtlich gehirn war
noch den grünen land ich finde was
sollte der cdu die freiheit geben ihren
positionen selbst zu wählen und die
nicht von den grünen bestimmen zu lassen
herr wissen mit wem könnten sie am
besten koalieren der da gerade zur wahl
steht
wir arbeiten ja sehr vertrauensvoll und
erfolgreich mit armin laschet nordrhein
westfalen zusammen glaube dass er ein
sehr guter cdu-vorsitzender wäre und ich
finde aber auch friedrich merz würde
eine kurskorrektur für die union
einleiten die ich auch für dringend
erforderlich halte herr lauterbach mit
wem könnten sie wieder eine große
koalition machen ich will mich da nicht
einen die cdu also kandidaten war dass
die cdu auch in all unseren mit also mit
riga entscheiden das nicht gemacht und
daran halte ich mich
hermann wer muss cdu-vorsitzender werden
damit markus söder kanzlerkandidat wird
über den kanzlerkandidaten entscheiden
wir erst so musste und in die frage wer
cdu parteivorsitz bewirbt hat sich die
csu noch nie eingemischt
herzlichen dank das war es für heute mit
die richtigen fragen herzlichen dank
joachim herrmann
herzlichen dank herr lauterbach volker
wissing und boris palmer für diese
spannende lebhafte diskussion und ich
glaube das ist es was ist auch
auszeichnet in der korona debatte dass
wir lebhafte diskussion haben wir haben
heute viel gelernt von den
unterschiedlichen seiten und sie
erfahren natürlich alles was corona
angeht bei bild und die nächste sendung
von bild live morgen herzlichen dank
einen schönen rest sonntagabend alles
gute servus wieder schauen und bleibt
bis fünf danke 100
[Musik]